I've always been fascinated with the
Himalaya I spent some time there as a
kid my father used to work in the
Himalaya and it is the largest physical
feature in in India and is responsible
for the climate of North India as well
as essential for the livelihoods of a
billion people that live in the
indo-gangetic Plains due to the
ecosystem services provided by it
biodiversity species animals plants
don't recognize political borders and
they move whether the borders are there
or not what's interesting is that people
also don't recognize political borders
to the extent that we might think they
do the indigenous groups there will
often cross borders which are thought to
be extremely hostile and disputed
without really thinking too much about
it borders have become a lot less porous
than they used to be but the movement
across border still occurs both for the
flora and fauna but also for human
beings and a certain amount of trade
that still goes on the Himalaya has
often been studied for the north-south
transsex the very very sudden changes in
elevation from about sea level to 8,000
meters or more in a very very short
distance however what's equally
interesting or more interesting and what
we are looking at through the el
himalaya initiative is the east-west arc
of the east-west transit from
afghanistan and pakistan in the west to
burma in the east and along this
gradient you have a large variety of
environmental social and cultural
gradients you find the entire spectrum
of religions are most of the major
religions of the planet are well
represented in the Himalaya it's it's
it's unusual to see such a small area
with all these various religions
Christianity Buddhism Islam Hinduism
coexisting and coexisting fairly well in
many places the
is also the sort of land from where many
major rivers flow and ten major river
basins get a lot of their water from the
Himalayan region and the ecosystem
services that flow from the Himalaya
impact about a fifth of humanity over a
billion people in the indo-gangetic
Plains in the plains of Punjab and
further north in Tibet and China there
are young and growing mountain range
which is very fragile where many of the
rocks are tend to be very crumbly where
says macaque tivity is already very high
so it's it's not a very stable mountain
range such as the mountain ranges such
as the ABS for example which tend to be
an old and stable mountain range the
high population that has been living
there has resulted in the fragmentation
of the natural areas and as global
warming occurs and global warming
interestingly now seems to be occurring
faster or at a at a more accentuated
rate in the Himalaya the glacier seem to
be melting a little faster the climate
change across the slope seems to be
higher it is impacting the way the
natural flora and fauna can move
especially now that human beings have
sort of taking over patches of the
landscape and the corridors for
migration of that flora and fauna have
been greatly cut down so the Himalaya
faces threats on several fronts another
major one is the development activity we
all want electricity and so hydropower
needs to be built but is hydropower are
large dams or even run of the river dams
appropriate for the Himalaya there's a
lot of road building activity going on
without proper alignment once you
disturb a fragile rock it's often very
very hard to stabilize it and roads that
are built incorrectly will result in
landslips and landslides that go on for
years to come the Himalaya makes an
extremely interesting research area and
in some ways it's easy to study the tree
diversity for
example in the Western Himalayas
relatively low but what makes it so
interesting and complex is the interplay
of nature geology ecology forestry and
human beings unlike other forested
ecosystems in the world you don't have
large swathes of forest and then you
know human populations on the periphery
of that human beings integrate very very
well with the natural areas they are
dependent on the natural areas of these
forests and pretty much all the forests
are impacted by human beings in one way
or the other studying this interplay of
humans and nature and wildlife is
extremely interesting